welcome everyone i'm delighted to
introduce uh zui la nguyen who is
associate professor in the department of
modern and classical languages at the
university of houston
his work which is at the intersection of
history literature critical theory and
philosophy
breaks down conceptual and disciplinary
boundaries that have long limited the
way we think about important issues in
vietnamese studies
he is equally at home discussing the
intricacies of marxist social theory and
historical materialism as well as at
revisiting the intellectual history of
20th century vietnam
he's not only adept at unraveling the
mysteries of jacques derrida or walter
benjamin but at teasing out the
political historical and intellectual
significance of vietnamese spy novels
from the late 1960s and early 1970s
he writes regularly for journals and
critical marxism and also forces us to
rethink the unsophisticated ways most
vietnam studies scholars have
underestimated
and flattened the intellectual
complexities of vietnamese marxist
thought and social theory within vietnam
in general
the results are provocative and
transformative and show a path for
engaging with the history of ideas and
cultural productions like literature
film and television as a serious
intellectual project that transforms the
world rather than just serves as a
derivative aspect of political history
zwie takes intellectual history
seriously as intellectual history it's
not just a pathway into understanding
the stories we already know about
politics and this is what he's done with
this book the unimagined community
imperialism and culture in south vietnam
which he'll be talking about today so
please join me in welcoming zui la
nguyen for today's talk thank you
um so thanks eric for that over-the-top
generous introduction which i certainly
don't deserve um
and thanks christine for organizing all
of um
all of this as well
um i've been a big fan of this series
there's been a bunch of wonderful talks
in the series so it's a real pleasure to
be able to participate
okay um so i'm just going to jump right
into it um and share my screen with all
of you
okay
so on september 2nd 1963
noting you the brother-in-chief
political advisor of the south
vietnamese president noeden ziam
spoke in secret with the polish diplomat
miyachutsuaf manali to discuss the
possibility of peace talks with hanoi
in the context of the deteriorating
relationship between the americans and
the south vietnamese the meeting raised
u.s suspicions that new was trying to
betray the alliance and forfeit the war
the crisis was stirred by an incident
that occurred several months earlier
in may south vietnamese soldiers in the
city of hue killed several unarmed
civilians opposing a government ban on
the public display of buddhist flags
the episode the episode ignited a wave
of political protests that would come to
be symbolized by the famous photograph
of
self-emulation
shattering the image of the south
vietnamese state as a stable viable and
democratic bastion of the free world
the photograph would come would become a
universal symbol of rebellion in the
fight against injustice
taking during the height of the civil
rights movement the picture appeared to
provide irrefutable evidence that the
republic of vietnam was a repressive
regime denying equality to its own
buddhist majority
the backlash in the international press
would prompt u.s officials to threaten a
withdrawal of support in a complete
suspension of aid at a moment when the
insurgency appeared to be fulfilling its
pledge to quote destroy the dictatorial
government of the american lackey
nodenzium
in less than two months after the
meeting in september ziam and were
killed in a coup backed by the american
embassy
the assassination in november marked the
beginning of a tragic comic cycle of
changing regimes and incompetent leaders
this ended in april 1975 with the
communist victory and the humiliating
withdrawal of american forces after two
decades of war that left millions of
vietnamese dead
by that point the republic was already
widely regarded as a political puppet
manufactured by the world's greatest
capitalist power waging an imperialist
war against the poor peasant society
so
seen from this vantage point
new's response to monali during their
september meeting seems utterly strange
and inexplicable
after a lengthy quote exposition on the
philosophy of the cult of personality
and its role in what he described as the
republic's increasing success in the war
knew unaware that the end had arrived
announced the beginning of a new phase
of the conflict
for the south vietnamese the war had
become a quote
social revolution against the communist
revolution in the countryside
as a total transformation of society
this revolution moreover
was not simply a nationalist struggle to
overcome communism
on the contrary nationalism according to
was a quote alibi exploded exploited by
third world leaders who failed to
recognize the need for social revolution
in underdeveloped countries
casting the buddhist affair as an
imperialist plot to crush the social
revolution in the name of a western
ideal of democracy
new declared the quote the war cannot be
won with the americans because they are
an obstacle to the revolutionary
transformation of society which is the
prerequisite for victory
this obstacle was identified in
particular with the mechanism of
american aid
which knew had condemned and
unmistakably marxist terminology as a
quote as an instrument of
underdevelopment quote
vietnam not a guinea pig for capitalist
imperialism to experiment on
the new phase of the conflict therefore
would call for resistance both against
communism and american neo-colonialism
the republic as new explained to an
astonished monolith is fighting against
both the guerrillas and imperialism
but even more puzzling than the idea
that the south vietnamese were engaged
in an anti-imperial struggle with their
american allies was the fact that for
knew the ultimate aim of the social
revolution in the south was not to
defeat communism
rather the goal was the abolition of
capitalism
just as the americans were now an
obstacle to the revolutionary
transformation of society so the quote
capitalist regime in the south cannot
effectively oppose communism
in another display of this penchant for
abstruse dialectical statements new
therefore explained that the
anti-communist war was in fact an
anti-capitalist strategy quote i am
really combating communism in order to
put an end to materialistic capitalism
so this apparently implausible
explanation of the political aims of the
south vietnamese government
has been taken as evidence that mu was
insane
as a symptom of his opium-induced
paranoia or one of his machiavellian
schemes to preserve his own power
but it's just as implausible that the
leader of a reactionary puppet regime
would try to avoid an imminent coup
supported by his neocolonial patrons by
suddenly reinventing himself as a
marxist opponent of u.s imperialism
and in fact new had long expressed his
opposition to capitalism for example in
the manifesto to his canal revolutionary
party where he writes quote the
capitalists have trampled on human
dignity
to build a career of wealth on the blood
of laboring people
news anti-capitalist party moreover
would play an important role in
establishing the odin museum's
government in 1955
a government which embraced a version of
socialism that was different from that
of the communist party with the
vietnamese workers party as new
explained in an interview quote we are
working towards a socialistic state a
non-marxist state of free cooperatives
where labor shares control of industry
like the idea of an anti-capitalist war
against the vietnamese communist party
the notion of a non-marxist socialism
may seem self-contradictory
given the capitalist communist binary
that framed geopolitics during the cold
war
and in fact this led one observer to
argue that the first republic was not a
catholic regime
rather the catholicism was merely a
cover for communism pure and simple
quote
new fastened his grip on the labor
movement in vietnam and this is a fact
that sometimes forgotten that he was a
political organizer before he became
part of the first republic
and you conducted the labor movement
under another name the humanist workers
revolutionary party which is uh the
translation here for gun lau
stripped of its flowery rhetoric mr news
non-marxist personal marxism should
never have been reassuring
um the do good americans claim that
yodenzium represented a third force
hostile to communism
this species explanation made him
acceptable to america's government and
press
in news case the whole theory was
wrought
many vietnamese were in the third force
category but noting you was never one of
them he was among the intellectuals of
the left
in their game the devout zoom was never
anything but a front
so this non-marxist personal marxism
which was the official doctrine of the
first republic is the same as what
manali called the philosophy of the cult
of personality the theory informing the
strategy that the republic was
supposedly using to fight the insurgency
and to resist the americans the
strategic hamlet campaign
so
is there some validity to node and news
apparently implausible account of the
war
did the coup in 1963 mark the demise of
a corrupt puppet regime pretending to be
a parliamentary government or could it
have been the defeat of a social
revolution against the communist
insurgency in the south and u.s
imperialism
so this is a question that i explore in
my book the unimagined community
imperialism and culture in south vietnam
and in my talk today which is taken from
the first part of my book
i want to reconstruct the
lengthy exposition on personalism and
counter insurgency which knew related to
monolith in 1963
um so what was this non-marxist
personalist marxism that new described
as the philosophy of the strategic
hamlet campaign
and did the noes actually conceive of
the program as an anti-capitalist war
against communism and finally what would
such a seemingly contradictory project
entail
so to give you an outline of my
presentation today the the first part
will examine the theory of personalism
and
and i argue here that personalism was
not a reactionary religious ideology but
a radical anti-capitalist theory that
also included a critique of bourgeois
democracy
this critique informed the noah's
understanding of the impact of
colonialism
and the noe's perspective um is
interesting here because it departs from
the conventional post-colonial account
of colonialism as being this
hypocritical enterprise that preached
the rights of man while denying them in
practice
uh for the nose the introduction of
capitalism and the liberalization of law
under the french
acting in accordance with the rights of
man undermined the communal form of
democracy or village autonomy that
constituted the basis of vietnamese
civilization
and then in in the last part of the
presentation
i argue that it was this communal form
of democracy that the noes were trying
to restore in a modernized form through
the strategic hamlet campaign
the program was not simply a
counter-insurgency measure
but rather a full-scale social
revolution aimed at democratizing rural
south vietnamese society while
organizing the peasantry into rural
popular bases
and these bases were supposed to serve
three related purposes first
to contain the communist insurgency
using a version of the communist
people's war
second to isolate the comparador
capitalist class in the cities and three
to limit the interference of the
american government in vietnamese
affairs okay um so part one
theory of personalism reactionary or
radical
um so when i began writing this book i
kept coming across
statements by the early south vietnamese
leaders that seemed to affirm marxist
ideas
which seemed strange given the
conventional account of the first
republic as a reactionary puppet regime
so for example mu during his meeting
with mona li
described the ultimate aims of the
republic in the following manner he said
um that is right i agree with marx's
final conclusion the state must wither
away
and then at a planning session for the
strategic hamlet campaign
you emphasized what he called the first
science of organizing mass movements
based on the soviet organization of the
communists in russia
[Music]
so what do
the russian soviet councils and marxist
ideas like the withering away of the
state have to do with the reactionary
theory of personalism
so to try to find some answers to this
question i went back to one of the
primary sources on of vietnamese
personalism which is the work of the
french catholic philosopher emmanuel
munie um and munie actually was
considered one of the most important
philosophers in france um
during during during the 40s and 50s um
in the literature on the vietnam war
um this work is often characterized as
advocating
a third way between marx's collectivism
and western individualistic capitalism
um so john donnell uh describes the
doctrine as an unsystematic melange of
third force ideas
seeking a middle ground between
communism and liberal democracy
but as the french philosopher lucien seb
noted the third way that meunier
proposed was in fact much more directly
aligned with marxism than liberal
democracy quote what characterizes
munie's third way is not that it is
situated at an equal distance between
two poles on the contrary it is much
closer to marxism the factor that unites
currents like the existentialism of sarc
and his disciples and the personalism of
munie and his followers is precisely
that they define themselves with
reference to marxism
so a seb's description suggests
munie's personalism can be understood as
a form of marxist humanist thought a
category more often associated with the
work of thinkers like sarc and luke koch
and anchi lefeve
munie's personalism therefore as node in
you pointed out in an interview with
lamont uh was not a conservative
ideology but a radical one quote
we are a reactionary regime you've been
told said news sarcastically are you
aware of the fact that we take our
inspiration from the thinkers of the
western left but you must realize that
we based ourselves on personalism
now uh the concept of the person in
personalism
is related to both the humanist and
marxist aspects of munie's work
so in this work the person is defined as
the foundation for philosophical
anthropology
the person is the ontological basis of
all knowledge and action assuming the
position of god within christian
theology quote
the person stands at the summit of being
and all being is subject to a process of
personalization
hence the metaphysics of the person will
provide the ultimate criteria for all
praxis
munie's philosophy then is a humanism
because it tries to explain everything
beginning with the pers the principle of
the human being or the person
but munie also opposes the concept of
the person to the egoistic individual
within bourgeois society
in a capitalist economy according to
munie an inversion occurs in which the
freedom of self-interested individuals
gives rise to what he called the tyranny
of production for profit
as a result of the free exchange of
commodities between individuals
money which serves as a means of
exchange
becomes the aim of production itself
subordinating persons to the impersonal
power of capital quote under capitalism
it is not money that is at the service
of the economy and people it is people
who are at the service of money
for munie then the capitalist economy is
characterized by a process of
dehumanization or depersonalization
through which people become dominated by
the impersonal power of things money and
capital
subjected to what munie describes with
reference to the marxist conception of
commodity fetishism as the quote
mystifications into which man has been
invaded by social constructions derived
from his material conditions
humanity is ruled by a sovereign economy
that humanity itself has created quote
it is not the economy that is at the
service of man but man who is at the
service of the economy
so here if you simply replace
depersonalization with reification then
you get something that looks pretty
close to luke koch's criticism of
capitalism
um
and in the manifesto of the gun law
revolutionary party new appears to
incorporate this concept of
de-personalization into the very
platform of the party
affirming the principle of personal
socialism new declared the quote
production must serve the people in
contrast to the inhuman condition in
capitalism where it is man who is at the
service of the economy
in munie's writings moreover
this depersonalized economy is described
as the infrastructure of bourgeois
democracy or parliamentary government
and munie rejected the latter in
unequivocal terms quote
we hold all manner of liberalism in
horror for it is the greatest and most
evil fraud in history
the most cunning and cruel hoax of all
and this hoax was a legacy of the
revolution of 1789 which according to
munie was not a popular revolution but a
bourgeois revolution
the function of this bourgeois form of
democracy that was established by the
french revolution
was to ratify the despotic rule of the
capitalist economy
in this political system the state does
not represent the people as such
but rather
the universal interest of atomized
individuals whose free interaction in
the marketplace creates the tyranny of
production for profit
in munie's terms the role of the state
under capitalism is quote restricted to
the assurance that these egoism should
not encroach upon one another or on
their betterment as a purely
profit-making association
although munie moreover was critical of
the soviet union his critique of the
latter was not that it failed to
incorporate the positive elements of
capitalism and liberal democracy
on the contrary the problem was that it
was incapable of completely abolishing
capitalism and the parliamentary form of
democracy that constituted its political
superstructure
for munie in fact the soviet system was
merely a collectivized version of
capitalism one in which the centralized
apparatus of what he called the massive
soviet state
organizes the exploitation of
proletarianized labor in the place of
the of the capitalist class
um so echoing marx's famous
formula for social revolution the quote
changes in the economic foundation lead
to the transformation of the
superstructure
munie argued that quote the liberal
stage of democracy will be superseded
only on the foundation of a new social
structure
in contrast to the soviet union this new
social structure would not be a
centralized government but rather what
munie called a communitarian
organization of decentralized
communities
liberated from both the capitalist
tyranny of production for profit as well
as from the dictatorship of the
proletariat which perpetuates the
capitalist institution of wage labor
quote by socialism we mean the following
the abolition of the proletarian
condition and the supersession of the
antarctic economy a prophet
okay um so part two colonialism and
liberalism
this this critique of capitalism and
bourgeois individualism was adopted by
the leaders of the first republic thus
in a speech generally swan or madame new
declared the quote
our union will never be a disordered
collection of individuals
each following the soul aim of personal
interest
our union draws its strength from unity
and discipline
so this personalist union was opposed
then to the market economy which
according to munie is based on
an egoistic conception of man as the
quote ideology and prevailing structure
of western bourgeois society in the 18th
and 19th centuries
man in the abstract unattached to any
natural community the sovereign lord of
the liberty unlimited and undirected
in the vietnamese personalism developed
by new
munie's depiction of bourgeois society
is appropriated as a critique of western
civilization itself quote occidental
countries had further structure
capitalism for their ideology liberalism
for knew then
parliamentary government is the
political superstructure of a capitalist
mode of production which he associated
with western societies
in these societies according to munie
the principle of formal equality and the
abstract freedom of egoistic individuals
conceal the concrete inequality created
by an economy based on production for
profit
um so this critique of capitalism as a
depersonalized society of
self-interested individuals subordinated
to the impersonal rule of the economy
informed the critique of colonialism
that new develop is part of his
vietnamese personalism quote under
colonial domination man is subjected to
money and power such a regime favors the
egoistic type of man against colonialism
the vietnamese personalist and
communitarian revolution conceives of
human value as independent of money and
residing in responsibility
in the early colonial period the
imposition of capitalism was accompanied
by an ambitious french liberalization of
indigenous law which introduced the
individual as a legal abstraction
instead of refusing to recognize the
humanity of its vietnamese subjects as
the story usually goes
the early colonial administration
attempted to grant them their
inalienable rights rights which had been
denied by the imperial court in its
tyrannical regime
embracing what alexander woodside
referred to as a social revolutionism
the early colonialists conceived of the
imperial project as an extension of the
french revolution
in the colony therefore the rights of
man were applied in order to limit the
political tyranny of the imperial state
as well as the domestic tyranny of the
traditional family
as the early colonialists discovered
however the attempt to establish these
inalienable rights would weaken the very
foundation of the non-western society
they intended to liberate quote
in traditional vietnam the individual
as james barnhart has argued was not
really ontologically separate from his
or her family the notion of the distinct
civic individual the fundament of all
western law was absent
by applying what marx referred to as the
quote so-called rights of man separated
from the community the french therefore
would unwittingly erode the traditional
bonds of community that prevailed in the
pre-colonial period
during this period the country consisted
of a myriad of scattered semi-autonomous
communes governed by the imperial court
whose seemingly absolute power was in
fact largely spectacular
limited to the ritual exercises of
sovereignty the coronation the public
execution and so on established suggests
the imperial state was a sovereignty
that was almost completely devoid of
discipline in the fukodian sense of the
latter as the daily exercise of
surveillance operating invisibly at the
everyday level quote the vietnamese
dynastic state was a relatively weak
polity without the ability to reach
deeply into all spheres of life because
it did not have at its disposal mass
communications means in a large police
force or prison system
owing to the weakness of the imperial
court and its tyrannical rule
village notables quote manage local
affairs and the family was the
fundamental unit of disciplinary
jurisdiction early french visitors were
struck by the remarkably decentralized
nature of social organization
in the pre-colonial period
the family in the semi-autonomous
village exercised a discipline that
preempted the role of the centralized
government
lacking the disciplinary apparatus of
the modern state the despotism of this
weak polity then was never extended over
the entire territory nominally belonging
to the emperor
this weakness is expressed
in the traditional adage
the right of the emperor gives way to
the customs of the village
in the pre-colonial period therefore a
despotic centralized state which lacked
the power of discipline presided over a
decentralized form of directly
associated production based on the
family
as a republican vietnam government
publication describes quote the social
and political organization of vietnam
consisted of two opposing and
superimposed systems at the bottom there
was popular autonomous democracy at the
top was the absolute monarchy which was
highly centralized thanks to its
mandarin system
the vietnamese nation therefore was like
a confederation
composed of numerous small communal
governments autonomous village communes
which sprang up spontaneously and
adapted themselves to the extremely
centralized system of the quote oriental
absolute monarchies
vietnamese society as ellen hammer
described was characterized by both the
highly developed autocracy and a
remarkable degree of democracy
now in terms of the relationship between
the base and the superstructure
between the economic foundation and the
legal and political order the system was
exactly the opposite of the one imposed
by the french
in bourgeois democracy the formal
equality guaranteed by the state
conceals the existence of concrete
inequality within civil society a
contradiction that according to marx is
characteristic of capitalism
in contrast the absolute sovereignty
accorded to the vietnamese emperor was
merely a formalized tyranny
an abstraction disguising the concrete
weakness of imperial power in the
democratic organization of communal
production
in news terms
the official autocracy of the imperial
state was limited
in reality by the quote democratic
nature of the autonomous organization
of the village and its independence in
relation to the central government
whereas the democratic rights of the
libya that the liberal state grants to
its citizens are abrogated as mounier
argued by the facts of their economic
existence the despotic authority of the
vietnamese court was abrogated by the
economic autonomy of its imperial
subjects the rights of the emperor give
way to the customs of the village
if the emperor then exercised in
absolute sovereignty over his subjects
this formalized privilege was
subordinate nevertheless to the village
and its extra-juridical customs
in contrast therefore to the legal right
of the king the quote democracy and
autonomy in the village as zeon pointed
out was not a written law look leitan
rather it was a customary practice
passed down from one generation to the
next
an extra-juridical form of autonomy that
preempted the people's subjection under
the law of the emperor
but as such
the autonomy of the emperor's subjects
in relation to his nominally absolute
power cannot be identified with the
inalienable right of freedom belonging
to an abstract individual
in europe as zeem pointed out the
establishment of this juridical freedom
had coincided historically with the
development of new forms of coercion and
techniques of control quote in
liberalism
discipline is indispensable all economic
activity is subject to the exigencies of
technique which is imposed upon each of
us and prevents him from acting
independently
during the era of industrial capitalism
these disciplinary techniques were
deployed in foucault's terms for the
purpose of quote extracting time and
labor from bodies
adapted to the colonial context the new
forms of discipline provided the french
with quote
capacities to control into course never
dreamed of by previous vietnamese rulers
which meant that
traditional village obligations to the
ruler taxes corvae services and military
service could now be enforced with
unprecedented efficiency
on the other hand in the pre-colonial
period
as xem pointed out quote there was never
an excessive centralization of power to
enable conscription of labor power on a
continual basis
lacking the power to impose a daily
exercise of surveillance the animite
state as one french observer acknowledge
intervenes only on rare occasions
it is indolent by nature
and as new pointed out
the system of imperial tyranny and
peasant autonomy underlying vietnamese
civilization was undermined um
by the political and economic
liberalization carried out by the
colonial regime
while the imposition of capitalism and
individual rights liberated the people
from the personal rule of a weak
tyrannical sovereign it also subjected
the peasantry to the impersonal reign of
the market quote the french
according to you have broken up the
organization of our social
infrastructure
introducing capitalism in order to
replace an economic system based on the
traditional village in the democratic
nature of this autonomous organization
um
so this this personalist marxist account
of colonialism underlies the nose
opposition to liberal democracy which
they viewed as a legacy of the french
for new the problem with attempting to
establish a parliamentary state in
vietnam was not that the vietnamese
lacked a quote indigenous democratic
tradition
having known only what general maxwell
taylor referred to as a quote oriental
despotic tradition
rather the problem was that this
despotic tradition was based upon an
entirely different form of democracy one
that was directly opposed to that of a
liberal democratic regime
the nose therefore called for the
creation of a quote um
real democracy at the base
against formal and liberal democracy a
grass roots democracy created through
communitarian labor based on a social
plan rather than submission to the
capitalist order
this real democracy would restore the
communal autonomy of the vietnamese
village in the modernized form of a
personalist system of decentralized
communities
now
insofar as ziam regarded this ancient
tradition as a sort of pre-modern
equivalent to the self-governing form of
the personalist commune
his traditionalism paradoxically may
have put him closer
ideologically to communism
than republicanism
but if that is the case
then the first republic contrary to the
conventional view
was not an authoritarian government
pretending to be a bastion of liberal
democracy
on the contrary
following munie's marxist prescription
the leaders of the early republic sought
to transform the parliamentary state
in order to establish a communitarian
form of democracy quote
um
the personalism that i advocate is a
militant democracy aimed at modifying
the superstructure of the present
government
now this personalized communitarian
revolution was not simply an empty
slogan or phrase
rather the nose tried to carry out the
revolution in a program called the
strategic hamlet campaign which is
usually characterized as a counter
insurgency strategy
the nose however uh for the nose however
the program was not a tool of
pacification
rather the campaign which the nose
defined as the primary objective of
their government
was intended
as a revolution aimed at transforming
south vietnamese society into a system
of semi-autonomous self-governing
communes
once established these decentralized
communities would produce what they
called a revision of the central
government agencies in saigon inherited
from the french um
so this is noted new describing that
process
um so here
new is distinguishing between his
communitarian brand of democracy and
electoral democracy
and in
the unimagined community i argue that
this distinction is vital to
understanding the first republic as well
as the reasons for why it collapsed
the difference between these two kinds
of democracy is often elided
and the illusion underlies opposing
accounts of the conflict
on the one hand i'm sorry opposing
accounts of the queue in 1963
on the one hand this event is portrayed
as a consequence of zeem's
authoritarianism
of his failure to unify the vietnamese
people by democratically broadening his
base of support
conversely others have argued that zm's
authoritarianism was necessary in order
to keep the country from collapsing into
rivaling factions incapable of uniting
the south
in these opposing perspectives zeem's
rejection of liberal democracy is taken
as a rejection of democracy as such
historians differ however on whether
ziam's undemocratic rule was necessary
for fighting the war or whether it
undermined the republic
i argue that these opposite views
conceal a more
complicated picture
zeon was trying to suppress liberal
democracy while massively expanding the
communitarian form of the latter
espoused by his personalist government
this was the aim after all of the
strategic hamlet campaign
quote
our government aims at one major
objective
the establishment of a truly democratic
infrastructure
although the noes then were openly
disdainful of the electoral machinery of
the parliamentary state they were also
committed to the creation of what they
called a democracy at the base
thus knew who rejected liberal democracy
quote reprimanded provincial and
district chiefs for not holding honest
elections for chiefs of strategic
hamlets
as new explained free secret elections
of the hamlet chief and council are key
to the success of the strategic hamlets
by providing the uh the means with which
to institute what he called basic
democracy on a local scale which the
people can understand the hamlet
campaign would preempt the role of the
parliamentary state and its centralized
form of
electoral democracy quote um
through the strategic hamlet
program the government intends to give
back to the hamlets the right of
self-government
with its own charter and system of
community law
because of the program hamlet leaders
for the first time as a senior u.s
pacification advisor observed were
selected by ballot in most of south
vietnam
for the nose moreover the
democratization of the villages was as
vital to the security of the country as
their suppression of political
opposition whom
of their political opposition whom they
viewed as members
um
members belonging to an elite urban
minority that had little support from
the majority of the vietnamese in the
countryside
thus while zhiyum argued the
parliamentary government must be
suspended
during a state of emergency
new pointed out that the war could only
be won by implementing democracy in
every hamlet in south vietnam
your press azim explained in an
interview
mocks the idea of respect for authority
and glorify so-called civil liberties
and the need for political opposition
but this country is in a life-and-death
struggle and even western democracy
suspends civil liberties during war
emergencies
as new explained
on the other hand quote
in time of war people think that you
must suppress democracy to win
to the contrary we shall use the war
against communism to introduce democracy
um
introduce democracy and we shall use
democracy to win the war this is the
strategic concept free elections of him
of the hamlet chief and hamlet council
by secret ballot are key
so these two statements are not
contradictory
the republic was using the state of
emergency in an authoritarian manner to
restrict an urban minority from
exercising democratic control over the
central government agencies in saigon
at the same time it was implementing a
program of communal decentralization
throughout the rest of the country
these two policies moreover were
directly related the nose conceited the
program of rural democratization which
they called the strategic hamlet
campaign as a kind of class struggle
against the french trained french
trained elite in the cities
in contrast to the rural population who
had supported the anti-colonial war this
minority according to um
consisted of quote bureaucrats military
um
officers and business people the
majority of whom had collaborated with
the french when the french left vietnam
the french collaborators became friends
with the americans
what the americans knew about south
vietnam they knew mainly from these
vietnamese
it's not surprising therefore that these
vietnamese were also the ones to benefit
the most from the from american aid
particularly the multi-million dollar
program to build up the south vietnamese
military forces
meanwhile in rural south vietnam nothing
much changed the peasants continued to
be exploited while the americans were
naively preparing the south vietnamese
to win a conventional war
as zhao suggests then
many among the elite in the city
subscribed to the formula recommended by
the americans for winning the war build
up the national army to fight a
conventional conflict while liberalizing
the government in order to unify the
south vietnamese people
as the nose recognized however
the aid program that benefited the elite
had created what philip katon described
as a kind of gilded underdevelopment
one in which the abundance of consumer
commodities concealed the destruction of
the country's industrial infrastructure
quote the importation of consumer rather
than capital goods created the illusion
of prosperity while hampering the
development of local industry
mr robert thompson noted moreover the us
commitment to maintaining a costly
conventional force that was incapable of
fighting an irregular war against the
insurgency would only increase the
problems produced by the commodity
import program quote to pay the
recurrent expenditure
on the armed forces the south vietnamese
government was committed to accepting
indefinite american aid on a large scale
including the import of subsidized
consumer goods in order to generate
local piastro funds needed to pay the
army wage bill
insofar as the republican army was the
main beneficiary of the counterpart
funds created by the sale of consumer
commodities its existence was the main
cause of economic underdevelopment
against the urban elite and the
americans the nose conceived of the
strategic hamlet program as a means of
decentralizing the war by building up
local militia while breaking the
republic's dependence upon an economic
assistance program that was perpetuating
under development
as new explained in an interview quote
my ambition is that the fortified
hamlets may form a new approach better
than trying to get progress as a gift
from the capitalist societies it is a
solution to the central problem of
underdevelopment in the 20th century
according to a report by a central
executive committee
of the people's people's revolutionary
party
the solution would apply the same
strategy as the one used by the
insurgency
initiating a social revolution to
establish a decentralized system of
semi-autonomous rural popular
basis quote
by establishing strategic hamlets the
enemy would then have the conditions for
amassing manpower and material resources
to build additional forces increase
military strength employ the civil guard
and militia forces to attack the
revolution
the solution to underdevelopment then
was to carry out a far-reaching program
of social political and military
decentralization in order to both win
the war against the insurgency as well
as to limit american interference using
the leverage of economic aid the
republic as new explained to monali
quote is fighting against both the
guerrillas and imperialism
and to end on a speculative note
i'll suggest that it may be
may have been because of the increasing
success of the strategic hamlet campaign
um
that was behind the nose adamant refusal
to liberalize their regime even in the
face of the complete suspension of aid
in a possible end to the u.s alliance so
according to a u.s state department
report new quote
will consider present aid pressures as a
welcome excuse to bring about changes in
the rural scene and perhaps in the whole
economy these changes will be based on
his desire to get the americans out of
the countryside in his belief that he
has a strong political base
now the fact that these changes were
supposed to create a decentralized form
of socialism in the south
suggest that the war during this early
phase was not a struggle between
communism and democracy or nationalism
and marxism
rather it could perhaps be better
described as a struggle between two
competing forms of anti-colonial
communism
thanks
thank you sui that was a fantastic talk
a lot to discuss here
so i'm going to open it up to question
and answer now
if you can use the raise hand function
on zoom please use that if you have
trouble using that
turn on your camera and start waving
your hand and i'll try to put you in a
queue um
well people are thinking of questions i
actually have a question um
i have several but i'll start with one
um
i'm curious
based on this talk um
where the
the
the nose concept of the village comes
from
where
you know i'm an anthropologist and so
i'm very interested in social
organization and those kinds of things
right
and it seems to me in many ways that
there's a kind of um
imagined understanding of what the
village social organization is
um and then when you showed that image
of the strategic hamlet it reminded me
of things i had noticed in the past
the the circular organization of the
strategic hamlet itself
um is very similar to a kind of red
river village form you know and going
back in like careful studies of
vietnamese village organization you know
there's a wide proliferation of village
organization and southern vietnamese
villages tend to be linear
whereas the ones in the north tend to be
these kind of circular behind the bamboo
hedge so to speak
um and
a lot of these ideas about you know the
the
emperor's law seeds to village custom
these are all like sort of folk sayings
that are quite popular but they become
political theory in a way and so i'm
just curious if you
got a sense of where their concept of
the village comes from and then a
secondary question to that is
you know they're working in saigon
developing these ideas at this time
about a kind of local level democracy
which is very convincing the way you put
it in some sense but did they have a
theory of how that would play out in
urban areas
um so the first question
i think the nose subscribe to um
parts of this kind of nationalist
mythology about the 2000 year history of
the vietnamese people that was kind of
invented during the colonial period um
and so just as the communists in the
north were
trying to cast their their struggle
against the americans is the
last um kind of um
act in this 2000 year history of
resistance against all foreign
aggression the noes were
trying to cast the strategic handler
campaign as the next stage in this um
this process of nam namdin or the
uh the southward advance which is um
this important part of the national
mythology that was created during the
colonial period and their idea was that
the strategic hamlets would not only be
kind of um
not just kind of a geographical
expansion of the form of the village
right um
um as it was in in in the um
but it was a
would also be kind of this advanced into
this non-western form of modernity too
um so both um so so that's um
would be my answer to the first question
and then
the second question yeah the geography i
think in south vietnam
uh created a lot of problems for the
strategic hamlet program and it was
because a lot of these villages were
built along
uh these canals that um
the program ended up needing to kind of
forcefully
relocate peasants much more than the
nose had intended um the program to do
different from the agroville program
because they wouldn't have to move so
many people around but i think because
of the geography they ended up having to
move more than they anticipated
um and then the last question you had
was about
sorry i'm uh
what i was asking was about the urban um
because this is kind of based on a kind
of vill an idealized version of some
kind of village com
com you know
democracy or something like that how did
they expect that might play out in an
urban setting or maybe they hadn't
thought it through
i'm not sure but they
but they imagined that uh the social
revolution that they were initiating in
the countryside would come back and
somehow revise the institutions in the
cities
um
but i don't have much more than that um
[Music]
we have a question from charles and then
after that christopher
hi zwie hi everybody um
zwie thanks for a terrific talk um
so
i guess my question has to do about the
the utility of
ideological interpretations of the south
vietnamese state
i'm asking the question because
you know the south vietnamese state
gauche has used the term archipelago
state to describe the drv state in early
parts of the war
against france and i think the term is
useful in understanding the south
vietnamese state as well
i don't want to call it weak but you
know institutionally highly uneven and i
think more importantly i'm
characterized by
you know always by a range of very
diverse political constituencies who
you know might not have been sitting in
the presidential palace but you know who
exerted
real political power um
so you know given that i mean you know
if you accept that characterization of
the south vietnamese state
or of south vietnamese politics
um
you know i just wonder again what the
utility is of an ideological
interpretation of of that regime um
i mean i guess this stems from me being
a little bit uncomfortable with
characterizing
south vietnam
as
you know
under the sort of umbrella of the
the ideological vision that you just
described right the fact that there were
constituencies in south vietnam that
were advocates of liberal democracy who
didn't hold state power you know does
that mean that we should not include
them in a definition of what south
vietnam was and therefore by extension a
description of what the war was
ideologically between
um you know as you described it two
different competing forms of
of um
of communism right
um and i guess my last point is that you
know i asked this question because i
fear that
you know ideological approaches to
understanding south vietnam have at
least historically inevitably been
kind of pulled
seamlessly into
these sort the kind of orthodox
revisionist debates
um and i think have kind of precluded in
some ways
um deeper understanding of south
vietnamese politics so anyway i'll kind
of stop there and and see what you think
um
well i think that
this ideological approach at least kind
of gets us around this pervasive
characterization of the first republic
as pretending to be something i don't
think it was pretending to be but like
you're saying
it did have to make so many compromises
both with the americans and with all of
these other groups in the south um
taking on the trappings of democratic
government in spite of the fact that
those were one group that repudiated
that um that form of government um
so um
yeah so i suppose insofar as the
ideological interpretation kind of
covers over the fact that those
compromises had to be uh to be made with
all those groups though then it's not
then it's not helpful
i agree with that
um
but yeah but but at the same time it
also um i think it's
i think it's
a significant
um
reframing of the war because
it's been
this consensus largely that they're a
conservative government on both the
orthodox and the revisionist side and um
but
yeah
i think sure
kristoff go ahead
um
hayes we um
i think uh your book is probably one of
the
most exciting interventions
in uh
in modern vietnamese uh
historical studies in a long time thanks
so i was uh
i'm i'm very very intrigued by by what
you what you have uh
what you've produced and and the
arguments that you're making
um
and i'm speaking as somebody who is not
convinced by this dichotomy of orthodoxy
and revisionism
when it comes to vietnam studies i think
it applies to some degree in vietnam war
studies but i think it's misapplied
in
in vietnam
studies i think there are other
orthodoxies
but but not not those
but in any case
i want to kind of piggyback a little bit
on on charles
i think your argument is is really
persuasive it's intriguing when it comes
to the thinking of the of the moves
um
but i'm wondering um
uh two things one is you know how much
can we talk about south vietnam as a as
a unit particularly after the
establishment of the nlf
um and uh you know the preceding
suppression of older viet min networks
that
you know must have riled up a lot of the
kind of long-standing networks of
revolutionary support
um
in in the countryside
um and
what happened what you know during the
time that the
the strategic habits are built up
but that is also the time where the nlf
is making uh amazing inroads in the
countryside by 1963
the nlf is projecting power
uh into
probably something like a third of the
countryside south of the dmz
um
so
you know
i see your argument at that ideological
level and uh at the
uh
government level
but
what are the consequences on this
in in the villages uh you know
where does it go wrong so to say i mean
like i i think this this quote from from
the central office of of southern
vietnam i think it's very intriguing
there's clearly
nervousness about it but still um there
there is uh an amazing uh amount of uh
territorial uh territory that changes
hands uh until 1963 and thereafter
and uh that would need to be explained
as well
thank you
yeah
thanks for that question um
yeah i think i think your point seems to
be like a little bit like the point that
um
charles keith is making about
taking this ideological view and how
that covers over a lot of um
important shifts so if you read through
the nose account and what's happening
you know from the beginning of the
republic until the very end though is
this sort of straight line story where
they declare the foundation of the
republic it's a personalist democracy
embraces this personalist concept of
democracy and then
they gradually sort of realize their
revolution when they figure out how to
organize this
strategic hamlet campaign and so it's
kind of a straight line but
it sounds
it sounds rather like um
um
that
they're not really sure at the beginning
how to
carry out this
this um
communitarian revolution that they have
in mind and they make a bunch of
compromises like i was saying to sort of
their political opponents in vietnam
um
i'm sorry
where for example they don't carry out
as radical the land reform as they may
have wanted though because they felt at
that point they needed sort of um uh
members of on this urban elite
um
to
to construct their government and then
um
so that later on by 1962 they seem to
kind of shift policies right and so you
hear the minister of the interior of
lung saying that we should
have done what they did in the north
though and gotten rid of this class
instead uh because now it's creating all
of these problems and so
yeah and so yeah
and so i agree that this kind of
ideological framing the story that was
excluding all those important moments
but i do think that it's important to
note that um i think against the
consensus story about why the strategic
hamlet program fails the causality
that's usually given is that
the program fails and that's kind of the
major catalyst for the collapse of the
first republic but it seems from all
these different sources
the program doesn't really sort of begin
to completely stall
until the coup occurs and so i think the
causality there is the opposite
and it seems to me as if it almost has
to be this way because the generals
essentially get into power establish the
revolutionary council um and they can't
decide on anything except for one item
and that is that they have to get rid of
the strategic hamlet campaign so on
november 2nd right they go about
dismantling some 800 of these hamlets
though and then the pace picks up after
that i think that what they're actually
doing is essentially getting rid of what
is this kind of front line
in this political war um that has no
front lines right so these are all the
local militias the cadre at the village
level that are trying to keep
communist cadres from infiltrating and
so um
and so even yeah and so
i guess i guess that's um that's what i
have to say about about that so
can i follow up i mean so why are they
why are they so laser-focused on
dismantling the the strategy camp it's
november 2nd 1963. that's amazing yeah
why i mean is is it that this coup
represents that the the
the the very kind of
urban uh minority class that
that uh the goals are railing against
are pushing themselves into power and
but i mean why are they
why are they so
focused on dismantling the strategic
handlers
i think the development of the strategic
hamlet program creates this sort of
antagonism between the nos and the
generals right because the program is in
part intended to limit the role of the
military
um
and so um
and so um
yeah i mean
and i think it partly has to do to
with the um
the fact that
the generals were largely sort of
excluded from much of this program as
well
but i guess you know i think i'll have
to leave that sorry this is this is sort
of material that's not fresh in my mind
right now um
but um
yeah i'm sorry i'm in the process of
finishing like a book on a totally
different topic though so a lot of this
material is sort of not like in the
forefront of my mind unfortunately but
zoe i i wanted to ask another question
circling back to sort of the
philosophical uh side of things
um
you you had talked about um
munie's uh philosophy of personalism
and in almost every statement
about mune munie's philosophy they
always call him the christian marxist or
the catholic marxist
um
and i wanted to take this opportunity to
learn from you about what it what
exactly when they say that
on the book covers and those kind of
what precisely about it is considered to
be the catholic side of this story or
the christian marxism as opposed to a
kind of
marxist humanism per se
right
[Music]
well meunier i think uh believed that
capitalism was this unchristian form of
modernity right um that somehow
um
god had been supplanted by um this kind
of pagan worship of these
objects right that now um had power over
persons um
and um but the funny thing about his
personalism is i feel as if um it's it's
it's
um
that it reconciles in a lot of ways his
catholicism with his humanism right so
the concept of the person occupies kind
of the same
philosophical or
philosophical function as as god right
um
and um so the argument that he makes i
think is something that like um like um
see
god intended to put sort of um
humans at the center of things because
they're made in the image of god right
um so he didn't think that his humanism
was in any way sort of
a contradiction with his
christianity
um
the thing that i'm wondering about
is whether this was the case with note
in you because in a lot of the
statements that he makes um he's
insisting um he seems to be kind of
rejecting
munie's christianity right while
adopting um
this this radical part of his politics
just building on that part you know the
standard refrain in a lot of vietnamese
studies is to talk about
the the importance for the nose of their
catholus or their christianity but are
you arguing in that sense that it's
actually that's the one thing they're
not interested in with munie i think a
lot of people would make the assumption
that it's because
he's a catholic christian philosopher of
marxism that he's actually somewhat
acceptable but is that a totally
wrong-headed reading of that of their
attraction to munie's personalism
i think he was different for each of
those right but for you
like clearly the attraction was less the
christian side of it i think though than
than the political side
um and so that's why he made makes these
statements to the effect that there's
there's no relationship between my
personalism and the personalism taught
by catholic institutions in
france and in vietnam um but i'm i'm not
sure if it was the same for exam and for
the other brothers right um but um but i
do think that the personalism that they
were trying to put into practice was so
so one thing i don't focus very much on
in the book right is this whole kind of
body of literature these pamphlets that
are put out though for the purpose of
popularizing personalism
um and i didn't like these very much
because they kind of remind me of
books you can still find today on ho chi
minh thought right where they make these
claims that uh personalism combines all
of the best elements of religions in
vietnam and in the west so the best of
christianity and the best of
confucianism and so forth and what they
don't give you is sort of this more
rigorous um set of philosophical
arguments this political philosophy that
i think you know is we're trying
um to put into practice um
but yeah there is there is that whole
kind of like religious dimension that a
lot of scholars that work on personalism
have paid a lot more attention
than i uh two than i have
we have a question from tui
yeah thank you professorian
i have questions uh in them
in
some of your slides you you talk about
liam
not new he said this about the under the
development of vietnam at that time
and to change it and they need to legend
the superstructure is very marxist
sometimes
but um during your heart i i don't know
if i missed it but
uh this he said about like changing the
superstructure but
and and under development is related to
a lot and they talk about capitalism
also
but
the changes that they they want to learn
new and the conflict in their in their
political
powers
is about
communism and democracy and they didn't
talk any say anything about a good
economic strategy or something
so like maybe you you didn't say here
but in your research
in your book another another part of
your book
did you mention anything about
the supercharger like about economic
development at that time or because they
are under colon like i'm not sure it's a
colonization
they don't do anything for economic they
live on the edge of the u.s
so that's why they
they own about
politics no thinking about economics and
the the
rural people like because of that
because they met they just focus on
politics and the politic is not just in
the in the urbans
in the center
in saigon so that's why the rural
imaginal
discussion political discussion about
the strategy i can i'm going to learn
from you i don't know
i'm not sure i miss it because it's a
lot of philosophies
yeah
see well this
strategic hamlet program was really
multifaceted program but a big big part
of that was not political but economic
it was a
rural economic development program and i
think actually they the nose actually
thought a lot about economics and i deal
with this in the book um but there's
also a lot of recent research on the um
the nose and how they tried to deal with
the problems of this of the commodity
import program the american aid program
and so i think for the nose that um
they recognized um
maybe too late right that the program
was creating this kind of comprador
class in the south this oligarchy of
wealthy importers of us commodities
right and that these commodities were
coming into the country and competing
with local goods and undermining
industry and then those complained about
this on to the americans though uh so
some of the vietnamese research on this
is really interesting because they
compare
the effect of the aid program in vietnam
with
a similar aid program in korea
and and uh the koreans were dealing with
the same problem as well though where
all of them these imported goods though
were was was making it difficult to
industrialize
and um the way that the koreans managed
to get out of this situation was by um
offering to sort of support the us
mission in vietnam and that's when they
got to renegotiate the um the program so
that more capital investment right was
coming into the country and at that
point though um as the war in vietnam
was um was beginning
they began to more rapidly develop but
they were having similar problems in
vietnam and so i think that was part of
the reason why the threat of a complete
suspension of aid didn't sort of
influence the nose in terms of
liberalizing their regime though as much
as um
as much as the americans thought it
would but i think they thought a lot
about economic development i think they
thought sort of development was was
actually key um
to
to winning the war right and that sort
of the
the american approach right of kind of
like providing all of these goods to the
cities um that weren't making them out
they weren't making
it out to the countryside and
building up this huge army and
liberalizing the regime right which
simply um continue to
lead to under development in south
vietnam um
but yeah
great we have a question from jerry
silverman after that question i'm going
to stop after you answer that question
i'll stop the recording but i will keep
the zoom open for a more informal chat
so christopher that's okay we'll have
you ask your question during the
informal chat go ahead jerry
um we'll flip that and christoph if you
can ask your question
go ahead jerry we can hear you okay i'm
sorry i'm getting used to the technology
um
as a political scientist i'm also
interested in
the nature of the
structure for
governance
at the village level
and whether or not you're talking about
closed villages in the north which i
also agree is a very different situation
than in the southern delta for example
along rivers
um
at some level you have a community even
if it's in a linear
sense
um
it may instead of a village or a hamlet
it might be a cluster of families but
somewhere
there's an authority structure
that quote
governs the
entity
and
i've been playing with the notion that
the
1929 global depression
had an impact on that social structure
in that
traditional elite leadership at the
village level
was alienated from the village as the
prior to the revolution
they were integrated into the
quote capitalist system
sending their children to school in the
district things like that
and that is that happens
non-formal leadership
replaces that
and that that's a major social
revolution in and of itself
and that accepting
everything that you're
arguing with respect to the nose
political philosophy and intent
they were just
way too late
because the situation coming out of the
30s
had already created
a quote modernized version
of life
political authority structures at the
village and that
that therefore the war was truly about
government governance at the village
level
and that's where the competition was
but that the nlf
based on the earlier vietnam had
already
started
you know they recognized that new
emerging village elite
as being the authority
and the french and then the
first republic did not recognize that
authority
now that's speculative and you'll
forgive me for taking you back to the
30s
but i wonder if you have any reaction to
that
um yeah the news
did backtrack right um
the um
the um so let me see
see if i can okay so
i think the program of democratization
the way it was
supposed to work is that um
instead of giving
the population
the ability to vote for
powerful interest in people in saigon
uh once every few years
the idea was basically if you can give
people
some measure of democratic control over
things
that mattered immediately to them
including their security
and you know which development project
they wanted to engage in that you can
motivate them politically much more um
than if you simply extended electoral
extended
electoral democracy um and um
and so and this is partly why the noes
were describing this program as a social
revolution as well right because they
wanted to get rid of um
they thought that by implementing these
democratic elections
and allowing
the population to get rid of kind of um
existing
groups with privileges right that they
can motivate um
the population to um
uh to organize itself right um but um
but i'm sorry i don't know enough about
this moment in the 30s that you're
talking about right when um
when when sort of um are you saying them
that sort of the colonial structures of
administration have broken down at that
point and already
you already have um
kind of a modernized
village structures at that at that stage
well if i could respond just very
quickly now i'm really talking about
well what i call parallel governance
that i accept the notion that
the traditional vietnamese
you know was that
villages hamlets i would go so far as
families
can govern in themselves
but that the structure of authority
within that context
had shifted
right
from the traditional elite
to the people who emerged
to the degree
that the traditional elite
had to some degree abandoned them
because
of the depression they had a choice
they could either choose
living in the district
or they could choose continuing their
role in the village and many of them
chose the district because they had
already bought into
the french colonial economic system
the elites in the village
right
and without those elites
new leadership had to emerge
right right and my speculation is that
it emerged within that that village
from among people who were still there
and that the communists
recognized that
and co-opted that new leadership
and recognized it
and the french colonial system
then the zm
did not recognize it
so that
even though there may have been parallel
attempts to democratize the system down
to the village level
at least in rhetoric
that
the nose were just 20
years or so too
late um so i
so it may well be that they were
too late in beginning this program but i
i think they did recognize the problem
because one of the explicit aims of the
strategic handler program was to kind of
build up this local
um local elite as a kind of
counterbalance to um
what the nose perceived as sort of this
french trans elite in the cities that
had
um
kind of been
trained in in this um like centralized
form of government and weren't capable
of acting politically and autonomously
and so forth though so so they were
trying to sort of recreate what the
communists were doing in terms of
building up this local elite as well but
it could be but it may have been the
fact that uh but they were starting very
late with it and um
i'm sure that
was a difficult problem to overcome
thank you very much
so that's the last question of our
formal discussion so before we switch to
the informal session everyone please
join me in thanking zoe for a fantastic
talk yeah thanks for showing up here
q a
and i will stop the recording